hey mr wonderful here and i've got an
amazing new episode of ask mr wonderful
because it's the kevin evans show yeah
evan carmichael amazing we're going to
ask each other questions
and you're going to hear it all this is
going to be absolutely spectacular
i think first it starts with you having
a goal that you actually want to follow
through on
right i think a lot of people set goals
that they don't actually care about
they set a goal because they see
somebody else doing it
and they think oh i want to do that but
you don't actually deeply
want to do that thing or your parents
want you to do it and you don't actually
want to do that thing i think it's
really hard
to have a big goal and stick to it if
you don't have the passion
for actually achieving that goal um and
then the second part is just having
a schedule for success like how you can
have a dream
but if it's not in your calendar it's
not happening yeah that's a good point
i've made a lot of money in my
investment career with women
ceos and entrepreneurs more than half
have come from successful women and
there was one
in the wedding industry she ran a very
very large online
wedding registry business and taught me
something that i now use today
it's very simple she takes sticky notes
old tech yellow sticky notes and
she writes the night before three things
she's going to get done
before she texts emails watches anything
or engages in anything or anybody
and she puts them on her mirror so when
she's putting her makeup on in the
morning
they're sitting right there and she does
nothing until she's
torn them up three things three things
i do that every day now every day it's
powerful
it's really powerful you know what you
haven't finished
the evening of and you simply put the
three things down
i swear it's so corny and so
low tech but it works and it makes me so
productive
because i get those things done
before anything else and they really
make my day productive and it doesn't
have to just be business it could be
some
personal thing you got to get done it's
a medical thing something else
it's just the things that really matter
in your life towards achieving your goal
that's the new thing for me that's the
next business
mr wonderful sticky notes yeah mr winner
i have a business that's called
mcsquares
and it's actually magnetic sticky notes
and it's it's we're crowdfunding it
right now on start engine
um it's a shark tank deal and the reason
i did the deal was the sticky notes
but now he has little magnets you just
throw them on anywhere around the room i
just love it and what you write your
goals on the magnet
yeah it's just with a with a felt pen
nick squares it's just a fantastic idea
and there's big ones and small ones and
because everybody's working at home now
kids love them you know there's multiple
colors
um yeah they're not paper but
they're reusable and that's another
theme these days but it's kind of
that that's why that was the crazy
reason i invested in it it ended up
being a pretty good investment
it's that it's reminding yourself in
your goal setting
that you need to establish a timetable
which
goes to your reference of the schedule
right i mean where'd that schedule thing
come from
i just think if you're if you're not
following through you either
don't want to do it or you're afraid to
do it
you don't want to do it because you
don't love it you don't have the passion
for it or you're afraid to do it
and you allow other things into your
calendar and schedule and you live
somebody else's version of your life
well how do you run your do you have one
where you're looking at what you've
scheduled for the next day after i go
through the morning routine
it's i do different things on different
days so today as opposed to my ceo day
friday is my ceo day and i think about
what are the big picture things i need
to do to grow my business
and also just stay in touch with the
people who could make an impact on my
business
so i'm here we're doing this here on a
friday this works
um monday i spend the whole day
mentoring my team tuesday i spend the
whole day working on youtube content
wednesday i pick a project that i want
to work on it's totally free to do
whatever i want
so wednesday is your your white open
yeah right
now what i want to do on wednesday like
what do i want to focus on and just the
whole day
because i think switching the switching
tasks are too high to switch
between mentoring somebody to then
writing a book
to then doing a youtube video it just
mentally maybe it's just me that the
mental switching costs are too high
versus the setup to make a youtube video
to do one video
you might as well do 10 cause the lights
are all set up and the camera's set up
and
and you know we've done our hair
i've done my hair too and and
and you're in the flow you're in the
zone like you're in content mode
which is a different energy than going
to write a book
so i i think being able to create your
schedule
around not just getting tasks done yes
but around just your optimal energy
zones allows you to be a lot more
productive
let's talk about writing books because
i've written three of these things now
this is hard work this is not as easy as
people think
i believe in the book business in that
it's a it's almost like a
business card you hand somebody it has
your philosophy encapsulated in it
but the actual process of writing 11
12 chapters i found very challenging and
each time it didn't get easier it got
harder
because i wanted to make sure i wasn't
going over the same ground again in the
third book that i wasn't the first
i i think it forces you to organize your
thoughts and get a flow to it because i
remember the way i used to do it is i'd
write it from 10
to midnight right try and write a
chapter and a night and then i'd get
really excited about it and i'd drink a
whole bottle of burgundy when i was
doing it and i think this is a great
chapter i get up in the morning and read
it and say this is [ __ ]
and that would happen over and over
again and finally i needed to get
someone
to bounce the ideas off and i started
working with a ghostwriter and i found
that really helped me
i'd send it to her she works out of los
angeles
and she'd say kevin this is garbage or
this is good
and why don't we go in this direction
that direction but it
made it a lot longer to do it but the
books kept getting better and they
and i could test them by how much more
they sold so
i'm working on my fourth now i'm hating
every minute of it
but i think it's going to be my best but
i always say that about every book
how do you do yours well and i like that
mindset too
is that i think you always want the next
one to be the best
one of my biggest fears earlier on was i
don't want to be the aging rock star
of being you know in my 70s and still
singing my songs from the 30s
right it's like the next one is always
the best the next video
i want it to be the best not hey go look
at what i did
you know when i was 22. um so that
that resonates with me for me um you
know
these are non-fiction books so to write
a non-fiction book i think that
a lot of the the practice comes through
all the experience
that you've built i think it's different
process if you're doing fiction you're
going to come up with narrative and
storytelling and all that but
this book came when i was on tour last
year and
i was hitting the city every four days
and doing a speech in front of a group
and
the questions that people asked me i
just kept
kept like a note of what people kept
asking me over and over again and then
it turned it into
and you you got thematically you would
get some very
questions over and over again that
people had right and say that is a
kernel that's an important question
because they keep getting it all the
time is that the idea
yeah i was i was on tour and people kept
asking me
how do i find my purpose how do i find
my purpose how do i find my prayers like
the number one question
in every city across america i said well
that's
pretty easy you don't have to sit on top
of a mountain for 10 years or
hire 20 000 business coach you know
there's a three-step process to find
your purpose
and i just guided them through and then
everyone say pick me pick me do it with
me it's like okay well
i'll turn it into a book and that became
built to serve
sounds good i gotta read that book man
that sounds pretty good
i got to find my purpose there's no
question
that's great i have been getting a lot
of questions about
um wardrobe as an entrepreneur
east coast tends to be a little more
formal ties are involved a suit
in the traditional days where you would
go rolling around to vcs and pitch your
ideas
west coast no tie that was the original
thing
and now i say it doesn't matter
it's it doesn't matter what you wear if
you if you want to be naked with tattoos
you can do that it's going to limit the
scope
of who you're going to get to see it
might help depends on the market
it might help but there is no wardrobe
for success is what i tell people
now it it's your personal style you're
reflecting
on what you wear i learned something
years and years ago
shooting dragon's den in canada then
shark tank and i work for discovery
channel
and i think probably steve jobs who i
used to work for at apple i used to do
his
educational software he always wore the
same thing
always and i asked him one day why
do you always wear the same outfit you
know that look that he had
the jeans he said i have 25 of these
25 of these tops 25 of these jeans 25
belts
25 sets of shoes i never have to spend a
second worrying about what i'm going to
wear
so i learned from him my outfit for
shark tank is the same
white shirt black tie black suit and has
been
for 12 years and i'm the only guy
that doesn't have to do pickups because
they can take
a shot of me 10 years ago and use it
today
you know maybe i'm a little grayer but
it's the same suit
and and i always wear watches with red
bands so that there's a continuity to it
so i'd argue continuity and
simplicity are really good if you're an
entrepreneur it takes that one element
and reduces it so that it's a single
decision every day
what do you think when i started my
first business
at 19 i was honestly even too afraid to
to talk to anybody so i did all my
business
over email i never went to go see
anybody because i was afraid of you know
disappointing the rejection
and as i slowly started getting out in
front of people i wore a suit
everywhere my normal attire was in a
suit but if i knew i had a meeting it'd
always be a suit because i felt that was
professional
but you'd have to buy multiple suits uh
no i had one suit i didn't have a lot of
money i made 300 bucks
a month you know so i bought one suit
and then i had a meet and i just made
sure that
that suit was ready to go um and slowly
i as i got more confident i
slowly lost the suit it just became a
blazer then it just became a polo then
it became
eventually morphed into this and i've
got at least 25 of these
which is the logo and branded and you
know custom colors and all that stuff
and uh now when i show up this is how i
show up it hasn't offended anybody i had
to give an award at a black tie
event so i wore my hoodie but i had
slacks and decent shoes on
um i think it's ultimately it's it's
opened up a lot so you got a lot more
freedom and flexibility than ever
i think just keep in mind of who you're
meeting you know if you're if you're
trying to go get
a bank loan for your company showing up
naked
probably doesn't give you you know that
might be your expression but probably
doesn't give you you know the best shot
at getting that loan um so just keep in
mind of the types of person
that you're you're selling into and not
only you know not dressing in a way you
would never dress just
to try to please them but just keeping
that in mind so that you don't offend
them because otherwise
you're putting yourself behind the ball
to try to get how about this one while
we're staying on on personal
um you know dress i met with an
entrepreneur
two weeks ago that had a lightning bolt
across his forehead tattooed it's
distracting
it's a big one and
you know you can't really get anywhere
until you address it because it's so
out there how do you feel about tattoos
um i don't i don't have any tattoos i
don't i don't
mind them for me i would work with
someone who's got a tattoo you know on
their forehead i like the expression i
think it just
it can help you in some circles and hurt
you in other circles i would say the
bank loan's a little harder
it'll be harder yeah lightning bolt
across your head it might be a little
harder
but coming to what about come with a
shark tank somebody came on with a
lightning bolt on their forehead
uh actually someone did and so uh
we're going to test that theory it turns
out
the tattoo industry is a multi-billion
dollar industry now
and it's also a community and it's
also a culture and inc has been on human
beings
since tribal times and so it is it
really i it it changed my mind to see
all the businesses
that were tattoo oriented that showed up
on shark tank because of the size of
that industry now
there's a health aspect to it there's an
ink application and removal industry
there is a maintenance of tattoo
industry i mean it is a business
and so i respect it that way so if
you're going to be leading one of those
businesses and you have a lightning bolt
in your forehead
i get it that's your flag and
i'm cool with it i don't care i mean
like to me can you make money can you
build a business
and their argument was this like
lightning bolt is my business
right and it's a good bolt it's going up
to the right
i like that i said i got it i i totally
get it
and so um i'm cool with it doesn't
bother me at all and i think it's it's
um
part of your your wardrobe really it's
just knowing your audience
right somebody's coming in they're going
to talk to kevin o'leary
you got to show them how to make money
and they can yeah if they can do that
you'll talk to them
sure that's why i'm there i mean i'm
trying to invest in opportunities
but it it it takes a certain amount of
discipline to
mark your face up that way because you
know it's going to be for life
even the removal of it is difficult
because the skin is so thin against the
scalp
so it's it sounds like you've done a lot
of research well i i learned a lot from
this individual and we talked a lot
about it and that this person was very
knowledgeable about the industry
and the new technologies coming into the
tattoo artistry
there are inks that that are more
removable for example and colors that
are more preferred that don't bleed as
much and all this stuff
who knew like but what really nailed me
was
multi-billion dollar evan how do you
stay motivated daily
you have to feel like when you wake up
today
the work you're going to do matters
that it means something to to the world
to somebody to to
some people might have a big mission you
want to you want to save the world
some people might wake up and just want
to feel of value to their
family that they may not have some giant
mission it may not be an entrepreneur
but you just want to you care about the
25 closest people to you
you want to feel like when you wake up
today matters it means something i'm
going to create something that's going
to have an impact on something so you
could be a mother caring for a child or
you could be
an entrepreneur with 100 000 employees
yeah but it's still it's a mindset it's
about how do you stay motivated it's
the mindset that today is going to
matter because if you wake up
especially consistently and feel like it
doesn't matter nobody nobody cares if i
show up or not nobody cares if i make a
video or not or
show up to my office or not if you felt
like that that's the path down to
depression that's the path to not
creating a successful business or
company or happy life
so how can you connect the daily work
that you do into
service into helping other people and it
will have to evolve and change you know
i've had my
youtube channel for 11 years it's not
the exact same i'm still making videos
the format's similar but the content has
shipped and evolved and changed over the
years otherwise you get bored just
showing up and photocopying your life
every day
so it's connecting on a daily basis
why does today matter what am i what am
i about to do today if you don't have an
answer to that question
you're not gonna have a great day and if
that's consistent you're not gonna have
a great life
i agree with that i would put a slight
twist on it
i want to pursue the things that
interest me
that um you know i'm a bit of a ying and
yang or i like a little arts i like to
play music i'm a photographer
i'm an editor but i also like business
so i i deal with my 50 plus portfolio
companies daily
and i don't i don't know the difference
anymore between a weekday and a weekend
it's all
blended together and i think that's the
new digital world
i try and you know have a routine i like
to get up early and work out
burn 500 calories on the bike or the
peloton or the elliptical whatever it is
routine matters but i always try and do
two artistic endeavors a day like edit
or
you know go to my recording studio
record some music or something that has
nothing to do with making money to keep
my mind
in in a in a balance and the whole idea
of being an entrepreneur i say that to
anybody listening to this is
you're buying your freedom you're
working really hard to one day have
financial freedom it's not about the
greed of money it's about the greed of
wanting to be free
and that's what i think and so i do
things that i really enjoy
and and i you know look at my schedule
each week with nancy who runs it and i
say
no i don't want to do that don't want to
do that don't want to do that let's do
this do this do this
why because i can't and i wish everybody
gets to that place there's nothing worse
than feeling that you're enslaved and
doing something you don't want to do
you're not in that situation i'm not and
i wish everybody
achieves in their life freedom and now
that may
uh be that you have to provide some
financial stability to your life
but you don't need to be uber wealthy to
get it it's just
what is free to you and and
i just don't think you should work for
somebody your whole life you should
figure out how to work for yourself at
some point
that's the whole theme of what we were
talking about today
if you look at your calendar and and you
hate everything on there
you're not gonna be motivated if you
look at your calendar a and it doesn't
have any white space and b
you hate everything you're doing you're
[ __ ] that's the that's the definition
of hell
so if you're if that's your situation
you need to change it you need to work
on changing that because you don't
deserve to live like that
that's horrible and so i look at my
calendar saying
this looks good this week let's do this
let's do that and you know there's a
bunch of balance in there you got to do
with family stuff and the arts and
business and everything else
and you can't make everybody happy all
the time so you might as well make
yourself happy
not to sound greedy about it just that's
just the way it is
evan let me ask you this question should
you lend money to family members should
you hire family members in your business
should or how how do you how do you deal
with the pressure of a family member
saying hey you're a successful
entrepreneur
i want to work for you and i or i want
money from you
i love working with family my wife
joined the business two years ago or
something
um i love working with family i love it
a lot it really depends on the strength
of your ability to communicate
and a good test is how have you handled
other problems
you know the first person i hired my
business ever was my best friend from
high school and i had to fire him
so that's a lesson but it saved it was
still
we're still friends it's how you
communicate i think that's that's
at the at the core of everything so i he
was writing
content i had a website before i did
youtube about a website we had 100 000
pages of content
and he was writing content from my
website and i need a content like every
day like andrew come on man let's
and he was like english major writing
the perfect novel and it took him
a long time to write a single and you
were saying chop chop let's go man like
what are we doing and it started
impacting our friendship and our
relationship
and it just came to communication and
say hey we just want different things
i'm not saying what you're doing is
wrong it's just it's not what we need
you know i need somebody who can pump
out the articles a little bit faster
than what you're doing
and i don't care if a you know period is
misplaced or like spending hours on the
perfect word
um so i've loved working with family
members over the years
i haven't lent money to people i don't
most of the time money isn't
the problem i think in most businesses i
just operate from i want to make money
before i'm spending it
so i've never had you know like having
debt i don't have i haven't had debt in
my business
ever um and you know pros and cons now i
don't even know what to do
now we've got too much incoming i don't
know what to do with it
yeah you're not making any interest on
on cash anymore it's very difficult i
get it
but it's i have no debt either i don't
like that i don't like what that does to
you but
regarding family i have a different
attitude now
when a family member comes to me and
says look uh i need money
i want to take i want to i want to
borrow money from you
and i recommend this to anybody that's
dealing with this problem
i say to them i don't want to lend you
any money i'm going to
give you money and i never want it
returned
but i never want you to ask for it again
i
if you if you're asking me to borrow
money for whatever reason
no but i'll give it to you but
our contract between each other now is
you never ask again
it's worked for me and it's very
difficult because of a very large
extended family
and i would rather you know keep
business
and family in in a separate place
because there's two
i can't stand sitting around the
thanksgiving table and having the
tension of
loans between family members sitting
there just destroyed
money destroys families sometimes when
there's too much of it it just does
and really it should be about being in
the family and taking care of each other
but that doesn't extend to oh i want to
open a disco i need a hundred thousand
dollars well no
i don't want to be in the disco business
you know the bar business and the
restaurant business those are businesses
i don't want to invest in for a whole
minute of reasons
but that i faced that in our own family
and i've decided
no loans gift never ask again
i like it that's a cool policy yeah i
would never do it for business
just because that's not how i run a
business like
go find a way to start smaller just
start smaller
yeah whatever your ideas find a way to
start smaller i like that idea start
smaller because it doesn't require too
much capital
and you can road test your idea and if
you can sell it to 100 people you can
sell to a million people that's the way
i look at it too
but i can't stand companies that
continually keep raising money
and losing more and losing more and
saying don't worry
i'm the next amazon the chance of that
happening is very low
if you can't be profitable after 36
months you're probably going to fail
that's the way i look at it so how about
working with friends or family
um i went through that high school story
you said and i
i did fire my high school buddy and uh
we are not the closest of friends
anymore
because um it was it was a contentious
see i don't like hiring friends i'd
rather say look we're in a business
relationship here
i'd rather treat it that way i don't
want i want to keep my friends as
friends
i want to keep my business partners as a
business partner so i have a
divide so i've because of my experience
you're a better communicator then i'm
going to whack you
but let's be friends i mean you're a com
you're a really good kumbaya guy like
i'm a kumbaya guy dude i you're like if
you're the fact that anthony's here
filming yeah my regular camera guy is in
quarantine is he getting back from the
us
so so anthony filled in but like if
you're around me you have to be getting
better
i listen i i appreciate that i mean i
mean
the thing is by all the metrics that you
can measure success you are achieving
success whether it be how you're scaling
your youtube channel
publishing books being transparent with
people that's important i mean you know
before
we sat down um i went and looked at your
stuff you know
because you're out there and you you can
look at
as you said go back years and look at
the content you're a very transparent
guy you
you you are definitely not bullshitting
people and you can just feel it and i
think that's very very important
not everybody can do that and that's
where your
your brand value is so i congratulate
you and frankly
i don't do interviews with people i
don't like i don't have to
and so you know what we we just met and
we you know we know of each other but
this has been great and i think it's
it's interesting that some things we
agree on some things we don't and that's
why it's a market
that's the way it is what has been my
biggest failure and what that i learned
from it
um i guess a financial failure
is is what we're talking about here as
an entrepreneur and i've had some
doozies
i've made some big mistakes one of them
i tried to do a cable channel with one
of the largest
telco companies in the us to consolidate
online gaming so you paid
one subscription fee and you got all the
online games we were early i lost
millions of dollars doing that
and i also got involved with a really
large company so everything was tied up
in bureaucracy all the time
it was a big mistake i won't mention
which one but you know i learned from
that i've never made that mistake again
that was my biggest financial failure
because it was millions and millions of
dollars
and it was my money and so it you know
it frustrated me
but the great thing is you know it
doesn't matter how successful you are
you're still going to make mistakes
but you've got to learn from them today
i like to say i make new mistakes
i don't make old ones but you're always
winning and losing
and so i make new mistakes now and i'm
learning and that's what they call
experience i guess
i lost a 40 million deal when i was 21
i could have sold my company i was too
slow
because i was trying to be perfect and i
stomped out the perfectionist gene in me
of now just go
release and create uh i got another deal
it wasn't as good
i mean you could have made 41 million
when you were 21. yeah
you bozo yeah i know exactly i still
feel it i still feel it
you're a kid yeah like we had we had a
biotech software company as my first
business
and we were building it and having a lot
of success and
the market was consolidating so like
this is our time to to sell
or we have to wait for the next round to
come however many years later
and i spent the whole summer working on
our plan for how we would sell the
company
and i picked the right market but i
picked the wrong company i thought we'd
sell to the number one company
and it just made sense but when we
actually went to talk to them they
didn't care about us
it ended up being the number four
company that made the big play that
raised an 800 million dollar
fund to go buy companies and i was i
didn't know enough
to go think hey the big guy of course
they're going to buy us not that they're
slow and lazy and they don't care it's
the number four guy who wants to be the
number one guy
so we got to the table three months late
they're already talking our biggest
competitor
and uh they said we love you guys we
love your software but we've already
done the due diligence with these guys
and so we're gonna go with them oh and
they bought it for 40 million ouch
now would we have gotten the deal
guaranteed if i was there earlier
no it's not a guarantee but 50 chance
but listen what you've learned from that
i mean that won't happen to you again
you won't make that mistake again yeah
and you're successful anyways but that's
my whole point about those mistakes
i i don't think anybody can be an
entrepreneur without going through a
series of mistakes that they learn from
otherwise
you know they have no experience but i
go back and think of how painful it was
and how i could have used that
money for other things and i pissed it
away on that stupid deal
but it i can't change the past so
there's nothing i can do about it but
when i
whenever anybody wants to get me
involved in a deal with a large
bureaucratic company now i just say no
not interested at all
i like small entrepreneurial situations
where
decisions can be made like that and
executed you can't do that when there's
21 people at the table for every meeting
every guy in his dog has a different
thing you know we we had lots of
problems with that but anyways
that's that's a fantastic 40 million
thanks man
[Laughter]
i had a really interesting question
asked to me on a radio interview last
week from an entrepreneur in california
so i'm going to ask you evan there's so
many zoom calls now
in business because you can't do
meetings right
and she asked me i have this really
sophisticated series of backgrounds that
are almost
mood oriented i can have the ocean i can
have the moon rising i can have the sun
setting or i can just have my kitchen
and my condo
when i'm talking to potential vcs and
you know when you put the fake
background on sometimes your ear melts
into it and you know what i mean
right so
i said to her i'd go with the kitchen
in the background like you're real like
you're really an entrepreneur in your
condo kitchen with the set you know the
dishes stacked up back there go
you know verite go go honest what do you
think i
i would almost always agree uh and even
this here we're like this is your office
it's not some place that we rented out
to film this this is actually kevin's
office that we're filming in
i see that as are you making a decision
out of out of
strength or weakness and most of the
time it's weakness it's fear
making a decision out of fear i don't
think is the right play where i would
say yes to is if it's expression if it's
this is how
just like wearing this is my expression
this is how another opportunity to
express yourself whether it's putting
the lightning bolt
on your forehead or switching up the
background so that you're on
you know mars or something but most
people
ask that question because they're afraid
of how they're gonna get judged and
and it's just it's going to show you're
going to be nervous they're going to say
what is this person doing
so they're coming out of the wrong place
making that this they're trying to
they're trying to give a falsehood
with the fake background right it's
coming from a place of fear
and weakness so i don't think that's a
smart play i like embracing the kitchen
better if you're pitching vcs show them
your kitchen like you're hustling you're
working hard you don't have some
lavish lifestyle that's okay maybe the
sink is broken like because everything
you put is going into
building your business but it just shows
you that kind of a question which is
very
thoughtful is it because of what's
happened in the world it's it's a
it's a present day problem because you
see if you could do zoom calls you can
tell right away who's got the fake
background
it's always their heads melting into it
and there's nothing you can do with that
that's a contrast issue in the
technology
and it's also ridiculous to have like
you know waves crashing on the beach
like you're sitting on the beach you're
not sitting on the beach
and so it's sort of it it now is a
hallmark
and people are talking about it you know
it's i think you just lean into it
though like i think if you're trying to
fool them
forget it like there's no way you're
gonna fool them to think you're actually
in a coffee shop or you're actually in
whatever because you're right your ears
are going to melt into the background
you're not fooling them but can it be
expression like if you had your favorite
guitar up on the wall or jimi hendrix or
you know
whoever you're i like that you know it's
sort of i have done things like that or
taken one of my own photographs and
stuck it in the background for a point
of conversation
but i probably do six to seven zooms a
day now with my own team and
many many other teams and zoom is not
going away
it's going i think it's going to reduce
business travel by 15 after pandemic's
over
because why do i want to go to san diego
if i don't have to and spend two days
getting there and coming back
why not just do the call get the
business done even though it's not as
efficient it still gets 90 percent of
the work done
which is great we did a zoom call with
our team
and and nina and i was live together
were married uh
and she put her background as a san
francisco bridge
just for fun and there was a moment
where she kind of became a floating head
in in the in the bay and it's just she's
not trying to fool anybody that she's
actually in san francisco
yeah and it's just expression it's fun
to head in the bay yeah exactly
it adds to it so i think if you're
approaching it from that like how can i
use it
to have more fun with my team to express
myself better with my team
by switching up the background or by
wearing something different right
versus i'm going to pull one over on
these guys and make them feel like i'm
gonna fight well there's another
piece of zoom etiquette while we're
talking about video conferencing and
i've learned
stick to the time allocated in other
words if you say it's going to be a 15
minute call it's a 15 minute call if
it's 30 it's 30. very few are longer
than that
but there's been a problem of time bleed
and it just eats up time it's
inefficient so what i like to do now in
my zoom calls
i say okay we're starting this at three
it's going to be over at 3
20. does everybody agree if you have
agenda items
be cognizant of the time and you know
put up your hands to have this thing to
talk about because it's 3
15 we've got five more minutes everybody
will cool with it
average zoom call is generally six to
nine people so you really want to make
sure everybody gets their agenda item
done
i found that to be very efficient at the
beginning say okay here's the timeline
everybody you know and what i'll often
do if i'm if i'm sharing the call say
hey five minutes is up we've just done
five
now we're at the 10 minute mark now
we're at the 15 minute mark keeps
everybody cognizant of that
very valuable commodity called time it's
but do you think it's a zoom issue like
if you had nine people around the
boardroom table you think those meetings
are going super
no they're not but but the thing is the
trouble with zoom is
because it bleeds your your day is being
pushed inefficiently in other words
you're not showing up on the next call
on time
mine are racked and stacked and so i've
got to leave one meeting start another
one it's a very big insult to show up
five minutes late
so that it's a zoom etiquette i say zoom
but there's
multiple platforms but most people are
using zoom right now because ease of use
and so at the end of the day that
etiquette is something that's being
built into our culture
so i'm giving advice to my own
entrepreneurs guys you start a meeting
at three and it's supposed to be over at
3 20
it's got to be over 3 20. because i'm
going to use something else right after
that
yeah i think that's just good business
etiquette i agree
i agree you have to go to a meeting but
it's it's sort of the world has gone
digital that way and i think time is
it's your most valuable asset no
question
and a great way to end it i've really
enjoyed our time today it's great you're
a good guy
i'm going to endorse you
that's fantastic listen it was really
terrific
and i think it's um it's going to be
great i know my followers are going to
hear from this so
that's wonderful thank you for your time
cool
and welcome to the office for as long as
like ever like everybody else in the in
the pandemic
i don't think i've been here for six
months yeah it's really weird to come
back here
and my staff too i mean they're here
saying whoa remember this place
just just think about how challenging
it's going to be um
for commercial real estate when this is
all over so many of us have realized we
don't need to work in an office anymore
yeah and not just need a lot of people
don't want to go back to it they don't
want to you're right
they're willing to live a different way
anyways thanks for your time today yeah
if you thought the first half was
spectacular you haven't seen
anything yet you want to hear the rest
of evan's answers
click right over here